[Musique]
bonsoir khaled mokhtar merci d'être avec
nous en direct ce soir
depuis les etats unis le conseiller donc
de donald trump dans bien de l'entendre
qu'il n'a pas souhaité fournir plus de
précisions quant on contours de cette
fameuse plateforme
à quoi doit-on s'attendre surprenant que
donald trump souhaite étendre son champ
d'activité il a déjà deux hôtels des
avions les universités dont il ne doit
pas être surprenant que donald trump
banni des grands réseaux sociaux
décident de lancer sa propre plateforme
une nouvelle aventure capitaliste à
mesure je me dis que donald trump le
lance sa propre forme cela n'a rien de
surprenant pour les soutiens de donald
trump
il est injustice il est injuste que
donald trump et de nombreuses voix
conservatrices soit exclue des réseaux
il considère également que ces réseaux
selon lui les conservateurs
il pourrait bien s'agir d'un gros succès
pour donald trump
ce retour sur un nouveau réseau social
c'est la victoire de la liberté
d'expression ou bien la défaite des
géants du numérique
whiting études sur ce raid 0 pour moi
c'est un exemple du rôle que les géants
du numérique qui sont de plus en plus
par 600 km et moins autres caciques
classic home valley qui ont longtemps
essayé de maintenir une apparence
l'autralie tv2 news
oui j'ai peur que les concerts la
terreur les incidents qui se moquaient
ils réduisent a pas de marché et qu'ils
ont essayé d'en maintenir cette
apparence de notre à l'été mais cela n'a
pas fonctionné
et les conservateurs aux états unis il
se semble de plus en plus rejetée par
cette forme pour donald trump c'est une
occasion en or lui même a été ben ali de
twitter de facebook et il a dit il est
donc temps d'avancé alors l'ancien
président on le rappelle avec 88
millions d'abonnés sur twitter
il y a des milliers des millions que dit
jean de partisans aux etats-unis 1
quand on voit les vagues 175 millions de
votes pour trump ça représente une manne
très importante pour ce futur réseau
social et les états unis simplement car
ce cours des quatre dernières années
nous avions des mises à jour constantes
des opinions et sentiment du président
il faisait des commentaires sur le
contexte politique qu'il inventait des
surnoms et tout d'un coup ils avaient
disparu
donc effectivement donald trump cherche
un autre moyen de nous faire part de son
ressenti à la minute et avec son
bannissement de folie t de twitter il ne
pouvait plus fr créé son propre monica
de sa propre plate forme pour continuer
et est sans doute que l'immense majorité
à des partisans de donald trump
attendent avec impatience d'entendre
nouveau ses pensées alors qu'elles m'ont
pas vous restez avec nous s'il vous
plaît dans quelques instants nous allons
parler avec vous de l'afflux de migrants
auxquels fait face le gouvernement de
joe biden depuis le changement de
politique migratoire puisque le
président américain fait face à la
première crise sérieuse depuis son
arrivée à la maison blanche
or coronavirus le président est accusé
d'être trop laxiste avec les migrants
qui passent la frontière
américano-mexicaine le gouvernement
tente donc de rassurer sur sa capacité à
gérer ce délicat dossier et la mémé
djédjé sage est clair ne venez pas la
frontière et sécurisé yuuwaa sous la
pression le secrétaire américain à la
sécurité intérieure
le tour des médias ce dimanche alejandro
mayorkas ce lui-même fils de réfugiés
cubains est venu faire passer un message
les candidats à l'immigration ne doivent
pas venir aux états unis des mots
martelés par joe biden quelques jours
auparavant accusé d'avoir provoqué
l'afflux de migrants à la frontière
américano-mexicaine le gouvernement
weiden tentent désormais de rectifier le
tir
le camp républicain mais aussi certains
démocrates reprochent au locataire de la
maison blanche d'avoir créé un appel
d'air
au delà de l'afflux de migrants le sort
des enfants isolés est aussi polémique
je viens de quitter le centre de
traitement des frontières des centaines
d'enfants entassés dans de grandes
pièces ouvertes
j'ai retenu mes larmes alors qu'une
jeune fille de 13 ans sangloter de façon
incontrôlable en expliquant par
l'intermédiaire d'un traducteur
à quel point elle était terrifiée
d'avoir été séparé de sa grand-mère et
sans ses parents
les etats-unis sont confrontés à une
arrivée sans précédent de mineurs isolés
ils sont aujourd'hui 15 milles sur le
territoire américain
un tiers de ces enfants sont retenus
parfois plus de dix jours dans des
centres destinés aux adultes
pourtant la loi américaine impose un
transit de 72 heures maximum pour ces
mineurs avant un placement dans des
familles d'accueil
de son côté donald trump n'a pas hésité
à s'engouffrer dans la brèche
tout ce qu'il y avait à faire c'était de
maintenir en mode pilote automatique un
système qui fonctionne bien
au lieu de cela en l'espace de quelques
semaines l'administration byden a
transformé un triomphe national en
désastre national
notre pays est en train d'être détruit à
la frontière sud
dès son arrivée à la maison blanche joe
biden a suspendu le financement du mur
prévus à la frontière
américano-mexicaine
au même moment le 46e président des
états unis a décidé d'appliquer un
moratoire de 100 jours sur les
expulsions de sans papiers est
d'admettre des demandeurs d'asile en
attente depuis plusieurs mois dans des
camps au mexique démesures vus comme un
feu vert par les candidats à
l'immigration les réseaux de passeurs
pour l'instant le gouvernement byden
refuse d'employer le terme de crise
migratoire
mais si la situation père
sur le président américain n'exclut pas
se rendre prochainement à la frontière
mexicaine et nous sommes toujours en
direct avec caleb maupin depuis les
cieux de dirt et america 100000 un
migrant fin février soit on a entendu
une augmentation de 28% par rapport à
janvier on peut dire que biden a ouvert
les portes du pays et créer comme on l'a
vu une forme de crise migratoire
donnerai pas comme ça le plus important
ici c'est à l'hypocrisie la présidence
coup droit très il avait beaucoup et le
son dans l'oral dans les médias il
n'attend décès de justin comme sauveteur
cruel sa liste
quelqu'un qui est emprisonné des enfants
il avait une coordination en général de
demain le truck en tant que consultant
au monde cruel
c'est monstrueux c'est même continue
sous joe biden nous avons des centres
détention pour des enfants migrants nous
avons des enfants parce qu'ils y passent
la frontière des gens désespérés qui
tentent d'arriver aux états unis est
plutôt que de le faire la morale les
médias traditionnels américains semblent
presque chez blier ou souhait de
l'administration américaine et elle ne
pas diffuser ces images terribles de
cette prise est véritablement
humanitaire il ya des gens véritablement
désespérée en amérique du sud et du
centre qui a essaye de passer à l'ennemi
que c'est le résultat des politiques
étrangères des états unis qui arment et
forment des extrémistes des cartels pour
lutter contre le socialisme le
communisme au nicaragua honduras au
guatemala
c'est cette politique le gouvernement
américain qui a encouragé le chaos afin
d'imposer
le néolibéralisme de marché des humains
qu'ils ont provoqué le coup par exemple
au honduras et beaucoup de personnes
dans ces régions n'ont pas accès à l'eau
courante à l'électricité n'est pas le
même à l'espagnol mais toujours des
langues indigènes
c'est le résultat des politiques
américaines et non ceux là on ignore
complètement donald trump a joué sur la
peur de migrants afin de flatter sa base
électorale
joe byden prétend être plus clémente les
humains mais la situation à la mène et
les médias ont changé de ton c'est cela
le véritable sujet c'est l'hypocrisie
des médias comment réagir l'opinion
publique
justement il a une sorte d' outrage très
sélectif lorsque donald trump milliards
oui ils étaient des enfants dans les
centres les médias ont lancé une
hystérie collective contre le parti
républicain
aujourd'hui ces mêmes forces face aux
mêmes politiques de détention de mineurs
de centres de détention immédiat comme
le bénéfice du doute à joe biden dix ans
qui ne serait pas correct de montrer des
photos d'enfants en cage dans les médias
c'est vraiment l'hypocrisie du parti
démocrate et il n'y a aucune
conversation sur aucune discussion sur
la racine de ce mal à la racine et en
les politiques étrangères américain et
le commerce le libéral qui a dévasté des
régions entières
c'est en essayant de construire à un
système capitaliste générale universelle
et cela a dévasté l'ohio la pennsylvanie
le guatemala et bien d'autres pays on ne
parle pas de la cause du mal on condamne
simplement ou morales les républicains
et îliens ferme les yeux lorsque ce sont
les démocrates au pouvoir et alors
qu'ils mènent elles mêmes politiques le
même capitalisme universel
merci caleb un mot par correspondant
d'arte et aux etats unis d'avoir été
avec nous ce soir pour vu de l'extérieur
merci à vous